I think now I'm starting to think a lot
about like how everyone's gonna look
back at this time and miss it and like
I'm already thinking about like 18
months from now and everyone's like man
that wasn't so bad you know you know and
so like I'm already kind of laughing
about like the next part I'm the only
thing really running through my mind is
I hope we don't go back too soon and
then we have like I don't think people
have it in them to go back hardcore
Quarantine like in Japan
this is one region people went out for
three weeks and then boom they had to go
back for a month five weeks and I just I
can't see America dealing with that well
you know coming out and then boom like
back in that like I just think people
gonna go crazy so I'm hoping that you
know we we wait that extra week but
we'll see I mean people are out there
already I would strongly suggest
everybody everyone you need to assume
the worst case scenario I'm not talking
about getting sick coronaviruses got
nothing on the economic virus you're
about to experience every human being
all they're talking about is corona on
TV look seven billion people about to
get the flu it's called the financial
flu seven billion people unless you're
let's take to 2 billion people off 2
billion people that are in poverty will
not experience any change in their
economic situation 5 billion people are
about to experience the financial flow
you need to commit you need to make a
personal commitment you and your family
hey we're not going to contracting this
thing even if I got to go home and I got
to sit in my house for two weeks I'm
committed to expansion in my home not to
Netflix if you don't do that you're
going to get smaller at the end of this
remember 2008 2009 and 2010 there was so
much money made it was unbelievable
because the world went to sleep and a
handful of people said I am committed to
my expansion number 3 follow the money
follow the money where's the money got
to go food water housing I don't have to
buy a house but I got to live
I need some place to live okay follow
the money where is money gonna move to
now where does money have to move to I
talk about the currents where do the
currents flow to is where you want to go
to if you're if you haven't been good at
your job there's a real good chance
heads up you're gonna get laid off here
okay we have three and a half percent
unemployment I'm again I'm not trying to
tell everybody panic but you're you're
you I've said it so many times if you
don't discipline yourself the planet
will give you an ass whoopin bellman
waiters uber drivers masseuses plumbers
contractors roofers car dealers car
salesmen insurance brokers mortgage
brokers folks if you haven't been great
great at your job there's a real good
chance you're about to be laid off okay
what are you doing that deal first you
plan water food you don't want to be
worried about feeding yourself to commit
to expansion I got to get my game on now
okay don't don't worry about to pass get
your game on commit to expansion three
follow the money where could you go now
that money has to flow to and you tap
into that revenue stream okay the world
will not come to an end it might slow
down but it won't stop number four
remember persists regardless no matter
how bad this thing gets you have to
persist because others will quit they
will quit trust me it will get tough it
will get hard when the hard what is the
old saying wind up when it when the when
the tote when a tough get going I don't
know what it is when the going gets
tough the tough get going something like
that and number five okay do you want to
take advantage right now you want to
exploit you want to exploit the
distraction exploit the distraction I'm
not talking about taking advantage of
the coronavirus I'm talking about
exploit weaknesses this is straight out
of the 10x rule find out what other
people won't do and do it how how do how
does a viewer who has all this content
being hit up all over the place you know
how does a viewer decipher between the
level of credibility being given to any
of these conspiracy theories that are
being spread and to know what is factual
what is just people who have a lot of
time on their hands who sit there and
panic and they're worried and they share
all this fear and people are sitting
there looking at the stuff with a full
level of credibility how do you decipher
between reality the truth facts and
conspiracy
well they there's another guy is talking
about coronavirus at so Martin's and
Chris Martenson and he and Adam Taggart
his partner in the business it's not the
most important thing you got to have is
your team your your core support group
team yeah well and people talk about
team all the time but this is what
fuller taught me it's a synergy of
different professions so I have like a
bookkeeper you know people have
QuickBooks
I have bookkeeper a human being I have
Tom wheelwright my accountant as my tax
guy if Garrett sent my general counsel
you know I have Kenny McLeroy who runs
my death Department he's my partner in
real estate and we have Josh and Lisa
Lannon who are into addictions because
we're all addicted to something you know
- food Chinese food but anyway you know
that sucks I'm gaining weight sitting at
home because of my addiction so the most
important thing is is to have the
integrity of a team a team that will
call you when you're all out of line or
at least question you because we we all
have a light side and a dark side and my
dark side is very dark I quite enjoy it
and you know you could call it negative
but the reason I am prepared today is I
don't trust my government I don't trust
the Fed you know when I read crunch of
giants and I'm gonna rope this book here
fake you know this is 2019 fake money
fake teachers fake assets it's fake
money the fiat currency that's why I
recommend Bitcoin and gold and silver
just because they're outside the system
you know Bitcoin is open source so you
know the feds gonna come after all
I know they're gonna come after and so
they're gonna create their own Bitcoin
because well that's my Satoshi Nakamoto
SSS I don't know I don't know if he's
really either but he disappeared from
sight you know because he came out in
2009 right after the subprime crash in
2008 I think here there was disappeared
or he was smart enough to disappear
because you're messing with some very
very big players do you know like I'm
messing with the academic system and the
finance system and when I crossed into
coronavirus and the pandemic I was
warned you know I was pounded pounded on
social media they said you stay out of
this one because pharmaceuticals and
insurances big business so the thing is
is the most important thing is just like
that book Atlas Shrugged you know the
capitalists go into hiding and so I'm I
have several places where I hide but I
also hide like we're hiding right now in
plain sight in social media so I get
together unzoom with my team and all
this and we might broadcast my level
meeting to show you what a real team
looks like what a real business team you
know rugby team is one team football is
one team soccer is one team but if you
ever see our real business team it's
interesting so we're a small
entrepreneur group but we're produce
incredible results I mean I make
millions tax-free because I play by the
same rules the corporation's do if
you're us if you're a pizza shop owner
you're playing by the small rules so
you've got to have these good advisers
and all this I always have general
counsel and I don't want to break the
rules but when social media they found
out of me stay out of stay out of the
virus you know don't talk about Bill
Gates having human testing yesterday
Jesus that was fast
but I understand vaccines you know
vaccine to be profitable must be driven
by the government
it must be a hundred percent compliance
so they get you know let's say I don't
know what vaccines the kids have today
but a lot of people a lot of parents
want vaccine their kids and what social
media does to get the other parents to
attack that parent and say you're
damaging my kids say well I love my kids
you don't love your kids so I you know I
don't vaccine because I love my kids
I'm vaccine because I love my kids and
really what it is is fear and that's why
it got to be a wartime leader because I
never hated the Vietcong I respected
them you know they were just like you
and me
I hit it when I saw their families die I
hate it when we killed him I didn't make
me happy do you know it was this lot
well we also fight out of fear who was
making us fight
I don't know today you know look at it
this way Patrick six million Jews were
killed by the Nazis but Stalin also
killed 25 million other people in their
gulags I don't know how many people
China's killing I think that's what
we're getting to in all of this
political correctness you can't say this
you can say that gender pronouns exactly
I think Jordan Peterson talks about best
First Amendment they're taken away our
First Amendment and that's what Stalin
had to do and Mao had to do you're so
afraid saying and talking to anybody and
then social dissed you know this thing
about you can't congregate that's First
Amendment to the right to assemble so
they're stupid on the Constitution and
so being a sick individual I said well
I'm really glad I have a second
Amendment rights because my social
distancing I can hit at 250 yards I'm
very good with a gun but I was trained
to do that you know we're trying to kill
people so my social distancing is I have
a very powerful Arsenal and I have tons
of gold at times but gold and silver and
Bitcoin how must the outside the system
and I don't need a job I love my country
I love what I do but I hate fear and
intimidation and when I started writing
about gates and
mandatory vaccinations I got told stay
in my lane and you know what I'm talking
about so that's why today we have to be
wartime leaders and be brave and
courageous and get smarter you know and
that's why I keep saying the best
teachers are on YouTube that's the
difference or you can watch pornos
they're both fun if you want more advice
wisdom guidance from other successful
entrepreneurs on how you can navigate
the coronavirus situation check out the
video right there next to me I hope you
find it valuable continue to believe and
I'll see you there and I've started a
company given birth was so painful